I'm just trying to work this thing out
president gave me a job to do damn it
but what do we tell you no more troops
don't ask for more troops what do you do
you ask for 40 handing on deck and
cutting out I can't hear you can you
hear me I can hear you okay something's
wrong here Hey all right can you hear us
now I can hear you
can't were you saying no no I'll talk to
you later do we need to put it so I need
your ear to clean up the mess this one
is a stitch right nothing about war is
easy bad I come here to manage this war
and I sure as [ __ ] didn't come here to
close it out
come here win
mr. president I you need to behave like
a leader but I am behaving like a dealer
I'm unavailable this country will fight
at night that country won't fight in the
snow we cannot help them and kill them
at the same time it just ain't humanly
possible you think the Americans call us
[ __ ] all day miss considering
agriculture a very bad thing to [ __ ]
your mother in our - in our serve you
gotta get me some traction you need cut
through exactly need to get me some
goddamn cut through all day
you out let me know that it's different
for Afghanistan you've got the gall to
kick the only Afghan in the room off my
goddamn table boss I'm pretty sure the
Afghan ambassador hears from Afghanistan
men are imperfect creatures left to
their own devices all they really want
to do is play with their dick and eat
chicken men need to be less
[Music]
haha let me come with you yeah okay
I'll come with you wake up I'll go home
with you what did I do
you